this is how they argue as far as i can
tell all right if they're right they
argue the point and they stay on point
and make sure you stay on point until
you're down on your knees apologizing
begging for forgiveness all right no
problem with that totally respect it but
here's the thing if they're wrong they
go rogue they go off-road
they start thinking of [ __ ] you're
sensitive about maybe you don't get
along with your dad and in their head
they just start concocting this evil
statement
totally designed this desperate hail
mary attempt
to make you so [ __ ] mad you just call
him a [ __ ]
that's what it is and [ __ ] trumps all
the [ __ ] they did to start the
argument now it's not about that one
there's no reason to call me a [ __ ] and
then that's it you're in this room now
right
my girl knows my big thing is my big
fear in life is to be that dude who
grows old you know grows old alone has
like that basement apartment
just screaming up at the younger couple
turn it down
that isn't music
so i noticed that anytime she was losing
a fight i don't know what she just feels
like that's why you're just going to
grow old and be alone then
i'd lose my [ __ ]
next thing you know i'm in the kitchen
washing dishes for the ninth [ __ ]
time in a row this is what the argument
was about i was so right what happened
so if you learn anything from my
ignorance tonight
just know this next time you're in a
battle with your beautiful woman your
wife girlfriend whatever and they start
out of nowhere okay you're winning and
they just start saying that crazy [ __ ]
out of nowhere just know in that moment
you've won the fight okay
all right don't get mad bob and weave
slip all of that [ __ ] maybe because you
got a little dick just let that slide
stay in the pocket of the argument
okay it's over the argument is over you
one just take a knee and run out the
clock all right
yes lean on the ropes let them punch
themselves out
and then in the end you throw this
psychology right back at them well maybe
we should discuss it later when you calm
down
and they won't hook up with you for a
couple of days who cares
who cares you rub one out
rub one out like a man it's a champagne
of victory
no means no that's another one no means
no it's like no it doesn't
all right
look look no means no no that means no
all right but no stop it what are you
doing
oh my god
you're being so bad stop it
no
that's not a [ __ ] no
that means i want to do it but i'm
afraid you're going to judge me so i'm
just going to make it look like it was
your idea so you don't figure out that
i've already performed this act with 40
other [ __ ] people right
but then
then you go to court and you get a bad
read and there's some guy reading uh
your honor she said no stop it what are
you doing you're being so bad
yeah and you're just sitting like she
didn't [ __ ] say it like that she
didn't say it like
that like i was afraid of my dad when i
was growing up you know anybody have a
dad like that you're just afraid of them
you know not like those sitcom dads they
come home the kids are like hugging
their legs
my dad pulls in the driveway you meet my
brother's freak like [ __ ] dad's home
shut off the tv
try to hide dude if i stand like this do
i look like a lamp he won't see me right
can i just [ __ ] chill out here
[Applause]
he wasn't understanding
when you [ __ ] up he told you you
didn't sit down while we're gonna work
it out we'll just you know i still love
you you what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
jesus christ you're an idiot
aren't you even paying attention
now [ __ ]
christ you're just like your mother
you're [ __ ] out to lunch
that was my dad no matter what he was
bitching about somehow he would make it
about my mother would have nothing to do
nothing to do with her he could somehow
find a connection and spin it back
he just said i was it raining out for
christ's sake i don't need this [ __ ]
christ it's the same goddamn thing with
your mother that woman is a [ __ ]
cloud hanging over my life
anytime you got an idea twice she shits
all over it
[Applause]
no he was hilarious
he used to work all the time so he
didn't really have like any friends or
anything so you used to talk to me
when i was eight years old like i was a
[ __ ] bartender
just dumping all this [ __ ] on me
like playing in the sandbox he'd be
coming up tyrion i don't know what the
[ __ ] i ever got married for
i'll tell you man i'm gonna get the [ __ ]
out i swear to god one of these days
when get in the car i'm gonna [ __ ]
drive out of here
your mother's a [ __ ] billy do you
realize that the woman is a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
is that too real for you guys you
[ __ ] know what i'm talking about
this is how screwed up my country is
right now do you you know you know brian
cranston right
that dude did a movie
he played a quadriplegic
and people gave him [ __ ]
be like why is there an able-bodied
person
playing a quadriplegic
it's like it's because it's called
acting you're dumb [ __ ]
see if he was a quadriplegic playing a
quadriplegic that's not acting
that's just [ __ ] laying there saying
[ __ ] that someone else wrote
so tell us what did you do to prepare
for the roll well i dove head first into
the shallow end of a pool when i was 23.
i feel like i've been preparing for this
role for my whole life
right what is up next for you oh well
they're going to do a reboot of top gun
uh i'm going to fly my prog
the co-pilot's going to be transgendered
so everybody will be happy
she won't die her discarded dick will
block her head from the canopy
there'll be a gender neutral bathroom on
the plane
how [ __ ] dumb is that that's
literally like watching a movie why
didn't you have a murderer play a
murderer and how come the guy he shot i
saw him in another movie
i mean what the [ __ ] is going on
so i've been trying to learn uh learn
how to fix [ __ ] around the house
that's what's filling up all this time
of just being sober
that's brutal dude you have no idea how
long a year is until you're stoned sober
that's [ __ ] brutal so i'm learning
how to fix [ __ ] right my girlfriend
doesn't like it because she says i have
a temper
you know
she's like you know it's just not that
you're trying to fix things that you get
frustrated you punch the wall the dog
starts shaking i just don't think it's a
good idea
you know you're a comedian you should
tell jokes he's a plumber he should
plumb right
trying to explain to her that losing
your [ __ ] is part of the process of
fixing something
right
everybody does that
you bought right yeah
you buy something at ikea you get
halfway through putting it together
you're like dude where the [ __ ] is the
[ __ ] oh there it is there he is
well honey i didn't see it
i didn't see it well hey you want to put
it together you want well they do put it
together you put together this [ __ ]
part of the board piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
instructions make no sense
i will buy another one i will buy
another one i'll buy [ __ ] five and
smash four if i want to now tell me what
to do
oh go to your mothers i don't give a
[ __ ]
jesus christ what story are you gonna
tell this one right not the part about
how i pay all the [ __ ] bills right
how was that uncalled for
how was that uncalled for i wasn't even
talking to you i was talking to the
[ __ ] thing i was talking to the
[ __ ] thing
i know what i said i know what i said
okay you don't need to tell me i know
what i said yes
i am working on it i am working on it
all right
[Applause]
look look you think i want to be this
guy
you think might be the guy who flips out
about the [ __ ] tables i don't okay
this isn't who i am this is who i became
all right i'm working through this [ __ ]
you didn't have to speak well you do
[ __ ] too okay you do [ __ ] too
well i thought you were going to your
mother's
that's brutal
i ain't having a temper man it's [ __ ]
embarrassing
you know
i don't know i'm sick of women trying to
every girl i have a date's always trying
to fix me
it gets annoying after a while you know
like you're not out of your mind with
all your [ __ ] shoes
right what is that all about i'm sick of
this hypothetical perfect guy go get him
go down to applebee's let me know what
you find
okay i've had it i'm working i'm trying
you go down and you get this mr even
keeled all the time with his little
[ __ ] sport coat right
you live with that guy for a while you
know hey honey i'm home how are you
hell traffic was crazy almost lost it
but thank god i had that book on tape
right
gulliver's travels always a classic
always a classic
that's the guy you want straight across
the board
even in the bedroom right
always making love to you missionary
style i love you your hair is like an
ocean
never know when you like to be flipped
over and have your face mushed into the
pillows you [ __ ] psycho right
ah she's right
she's always right
i do i got to work on it i hate having a
temper
you know i don't know if it's hereditary
i don't know if it's part of the country
i'm from i've always snapped
you know my dad was like that my dad's
the greatest dude i ever met in my life
and he had a temper anytime anything
broke in the house
five minutes into fixing it he was
bitching about his marriage
it was hilarious
he'd see something bro oh christ will
you look at that
god damn it billy give me that [ __ ]
screwdriver i swear to god what the [ __ ]
i ever got married for
13 goddamn years of this [ __ ] ah you're
a [ __ ] lady you've been a [ __ ] for
years
give me the fliers yeah most guys would
have left by now most guys would have
left by now
that was one of his catchphrases most
guys would have left by now and you
don't know how [ __ ] good you got it
lady
now when i was a kid i thought he was
nuts
then i got older you know started dating
i realized this guy's making a lot of
good points
he's not expressing them in the
healthiest of ways
i got to be honest with you i'm kind of
i'm kind of like jealous of the way my
dad gets to talk to my mom sometimes
you know where are all those old-school
women you can just take your day out on
you know
when did they stop making those angels
who just knew it had nothing to do with
them they just sit there let you blow
out the lines right
what a luxury
right to fail all day you come home and
download all your insecurities on this
other person
how was your day how the [ __ ] was your
day i'm out here making decisions
take these kids away from me give me a
goddamn drink oh with the tears
[Laughter]
then the bra burning generation came in
right now you sit there and listen to
their stories all the time
oh it's the worst you know what's the
worst is when they're telling you a
story and you want to listen but which
is what they're talking about you can't
even retain it
so i'm supposed to go out to lunch with
jennifer i'm all ready to do that i show
up she's there with susan she knows i
hate susan i look like [ __ ] susan's been
going to the gym i mean at that point
your head is like a newborn baby you're
trying to
try to hold it up
you know
you can't even if you're trying to pay
attention you can't then you just start
staring at their mouth after a while
like i can't believe it keeps coming out
this is [ __ ] unbelievable
it starts fading off
you start thinking about your own life
right why did i take nebraska given 28.
the [ __ ] is wrong with me it's an
awakening i'll send her a voice go ah it
goes up
right
i'm like [ __ ] that was a question
all right now what do you do can't say
yes you can't say no you got to come
with something neutral hey what the [ __ ]
you going to do what are you going to do
this is what it is you put one foot in
front of the other and uh
halftime adjustments ah i got nothing
i wake up a mess i've been smoking
cigarettes and i bet you couldn't guess
i've been dreaming
i'm impressed by all of your success but
i wish i saw it less cause i still wanna
get married you know
i was making that i'll definitely get
married someday you know i you know i
love women and everything i'm just
finding i'm not like compatible with
them you know what i mean
if they just feel that
like women have like too much energy for
me you know what i mean like you can't
have a day off when you have a
girlfriend you know what i said it's
almost like they see that open day
they're like oh my god let's go fill it
up with [ __ ]
no then they just come at you with one
horrible idea after another
horrible ideas like you want to make
some sandwiches and go to the park
you want to go to the container store
get some containers for your t-shirts
this is the worst one
there we get this one you want to go to
brunch
you want to go to brunch on sunday
and inside you're like [ __ ]
no but you can't say that right
you got to keep them happy so what do
you do you agree like yeah let's go to
brunch
what a great idea
why would you want to sleep in on a
sunday when you can go pay 18 for eggs
now you're thinking
now you're thinking
then we can sit around to listen to your
friends have moronic conversations about
the eggs like is that pesto
is that pesto in your omelet
oh it's asparagus it's asparagus i got
it with pesto
oh you just want to flip the whole
[ __ ] table over
it's horrendous
i'm trying to learn to pick my battles
when i date girls i usually argue with
women all the time man i'm stupid like
that you know like i dated this girl one
time she was like really into like
women's issues
so we used to always have these dumb ass
arguments so one time she came up to me
she goes okay explain this to me bro why
does a guy make more an hour to do the
exact same job huh
i go i'll tell you why because in the
unlikely event that we're both on a
titanic and it starts to sink for some
[ __ ] up reason you get to leave with
the kids and i have to stay
[Applause]
hey that's why i get the dolomar now
no think about it
if there's a house fire it's always
women and children first
i got to stand there with like the back
of my shirt on fire going let's go
people let's go let's go
so that's how i look at it
no it's a dollar an hour surcharge
that if something [ __ ] up happens
either i can't leave or i gotta like get
in the way of it to give you a head
start like rabid dog run honey one
mississippi two mississippi
you hear a bump in the night i got to go
check it out like yes he does have a
knife
anytime there's a hostage situation who
do they negotiate for first well at
least let the women and children go well
what about me
bullets hurt me too why the [ __ ] do i
gotta stay in the vault
no that's my point man where are all the
feminists in those situations
you don't mean you can't find them
there are no feminists in a house fire
that's a guarantee
you could take the most hardcore
feminist some chick right in your face
like he showed me this take down a [ __ ]
little short little haircut the whole
nine yards right
second those flames break out she's
going to twist those little hairs into
pigtails no i'm just a girl i want to go
play jump rope
and leave you standing in a burning
house like you're not flammable
you know but i'm not a dick though
i'm not i'm not saying i think a woman
should make a doll less an hour to do
the same job all i'm saying is if you're
gonna make what i make when the boat
sinks you better be standing right there
next to me listen to that guy play the
cello then you get the corner office
you get all the benefits or whatever
actually nerd jesus died in the last
year right
steve jobs
yeah he died right i know i know a lot
of nerds here tonight i know you're sad
didn't get it i didn't get the big deal
they made about that guy
when he died they were like he changed
the world
he wasn't saying
he changed the world the world was one
way
and then steve jobs came
and it was another
what did he do
somebody for the love of god what the
[ __ ] did that guy do
what did he do he told other people what
to invent
i want my entire music collection in
that phone get on it
[Applause]
right
and then these poor nameless faceless
scientists got to go in the back room
and figure it out how the [ __ ] are we
gonna get all of this
into this i mean
what year does this guy think this is
this is crazy this is like buck rogers
dude my kid has a birthday in like 11
months steve jobs just walking by i
don't hear any thinking going on in
there
just strutting around the office eating
some pretentious fruit like a pear
right
just throwing out ideas or another one
there's another one i just came up with
on the way to work
i was reading a magazine the other day
turning pages you know i like to turn
pages on the screen that aren't even
there yeah wrap your [ __ ] heads
around that guys
see you in eight years
where you going michael big little big
little get on it
right
then all these people slave away
to make his vision come true and then
they have the big nerd fest right
down there comic con and all their nerd
mecca they are all showing up with their
acne and their hulk shirts limping into
the arena right does steve jobs go out
with the whole chorus line of scientist
now he goes out there by himself
sneakers are no belt like it was no
biggie right
[Applause]
like he's
like he's tesla
tapping into the atmosphere i know this
is always uncomfortable i know you
bought into it right
that whole advertising the way they
aligned themselves with some of the
greatest people of all time jesus gandhi
me
remember that muhammad ali john lennon
this guy
how the [ __ ] was that dude like any of
them
gandhi didn't have a sweatshop
ah he didn't have people leaping to
their deaths only to get catch a net and
get ricocheted back through the window
to have to put together yet another ipad
john lennon didn't have children in his
basement pressing those
[ __ ] albums
i know i know
new phone can't fit the old charger this
is your hero
this is the guy
this is what all the silence is about
new phone can't fit the old charger so
then you got to throw it out ends up in
the ocean around some octopus's neck
do you realize how much sea life is
ecstatic that that man is no longer
walking the earth
that's where it all ends up you know
it doesn't go to landfill ends up in the
ocean you realize that i hate people who
say i don't pollute i don't pollute yeah
you do you use [ __ ] and you throw it out
what do you think is you put in like a
basket it just poof disappears
[Applause]
everything he ever used is somewhere
ever think about that
remember that flannel shirt you bought
back in the day when you got into pearl
jam
that's out there somewhere probably on
some porpoises face
trying to get it off
stupid little flippers
all the fads
remember rollerblading
remember that everybody had them
we set up cones we did little tricks
right
one little homophobic joke killed that
entire fact
what's the hardest thing about
rollerblading telling your parents
you're gay
full-grown adults dude i'm not gay i
don't have the cooties these mean i suck
dick and they just threw them out
they end up in the ocean
they're made out of plastic they can't
biodegrade they just break down the
little cubes fish are breathing them in
six months later you're going out you're
getting sushi you think you're being
healthy you're eating your old
rollerblades
all right i'm out of time you guys are
great thank you thank you thank you